but last year i was down in the dumps
because
i think i may have told you some stories
about my
uh friend from childhood wild man
and he died and his funeral was just
before christmas
and he was co-interviewing people with
me on my true crime podcast he was doing
really well he was thriving on youtube
and then he got ill he tried to get in
hospital they said corona
stay at home and he had breathing
difficulties and he went in
multiple organ failure and he died
within like
you know within a day of being admitted
yeah that's insane
i've got his picture up there right
behind me the big guy in the yellow
shirt that's him
that's him yeah he was the one who we
went to america
and he introduced me to all the mafia
figures that's how i got the criminal
enterprise going because he's you know
big tough guy
versus me you know just the the skinny
nerdy business guy
so he opened that door into that world
for me to set up the criminal enterprise
and when the swat team came um he was
right there with me protecting me you
know
in the neo-nazi jail he's a very good
person to get arrested with
because he was running around that jail
when when we got off the
the bus there was like 13 co-defendants
we're arriving at sheriff joe arpaio's
madison street jail horseshoe section
this is like a horseshoe formation of
cells where you go in
and you first get processed and it's
like dante's inferno in there
you are sardined into these cells
everyone just sat on the floor
squatting down you try and like get in
there maybe there's a little bit of room
near the toilet
and the reason is the room near the
toilet is because there's piss all over
there and it stinks as [ __ ]
so you sit down there and then some big
dude just
gets on the toilet and takes a crap and
the whole cell everyone's just like this
holding their noses
and they're all yelling drop one flush
one drop one flush one
because those toilets are really
powerful man
you press that button and it almost
sucks your ass off
it's like a b day spraying all this
water right into your butt crack
so when you take a [ __ ] the prison rule
is
drop one flush one so as soon as that
log hits that [ __ ] water you're like
but anyway in a cell you know like that
as those logs are dropping
the whole cell just stinks and
because it's the newly arrested people
you've got
people who've been in like fights with
the cops people have been tasered and
injured
you've got gang bangers from different
street locations who are kos
on site you've got homeless people
you got people just [ __ ] up on alcohol
[ __ ] up on drugs
a lot of people going through the shock
of the newly incarcerated it's just
mayhem when those gang bangers come in
who are like
from rival neighborhoods right away it
just kicks off and there's blood
splatter
then the guards come in they drag the
assailants out and if they're kicking
off they put them in this thing
called a restrainture and it looks like
a medieval
torture device it is a black chair
tilted back and they strap you into it
all of your limbs
and if you like are mouthing off or
spitting they put a spit hood
on your head and you see people in these
these these chairs just rocking back and
forth and like
howling like cats and [ __ ] like that
like mental
patience so anyway this is the absolute
bedlam we arrived at shortly after we
were all swat team raided
may 16 2002 i said i had about 200
people working for me on one of the
previous
interviews i did with you and they
started to arrest those people in groups
so they had the continuous criminal
enterprise you know the crime
uh family uh they're like a
pecking order now at i was at the top
wild woman was number two wild man's
girlfriend and wild man was number three
so that wild woman above wild man she
was as tough as he was man if
some people were more scared of her than
him seriously
their relationship it's it's uh you know
it's um
terrible that domestic violence exists
in the world but their relationship was
based on domestic violence
you know i saw i sort of fight you
sometimes
he'd hit a she'd grab a knife stab him
in the belly
sometimes they'd both be in hospital but
they were like cave people
i was saying you guys are gonna kill
each other one of these days and then
the very next day
after having these fights they'd be like
love you love you
and it was all about the makeup sex
completely off the scale
so wild woman i'm setting the scene for
what happens still when we get out of
this van
wild woman is from liverpool
the accent is so thick in liverpool they
said that if there was if it had gone to
trial
in arizona they would have had to get
her an interpretator
so i'll give you an example
giza sigi have you any idea what that
means no
allah kisiki
what does that mean what do you say that
means here you are
my lad give me a cigarette
la is like mate so she's like
anyway she was totally battle-hardened
man she was
a big woman at one point in time but
she'd been hammering the crystal meth
and she was only tiny but she was as
tough as [ __ ]
i mean i'll tell you a story in a minute
about what happened to the women when
they actually got in there
so we're all getting out of this van
we've
i told you previously about the swat
team raid what happened next was they
took us all to
uh tempe police station did they built
this outdoor processing center
specifically for me and my co-defendants
so we're all getting processed at this
outdoor processing center
then they start filtering us over to
tempe jail
in tempe jail uh i'm realizing the
gravity of the situation because more
i'm figuring right you know they've
raided my house i quit trafficking a
year ago there's no drugs
what can they do maybe they can release
me but as more people start to show up
at the jail
i'll give you another example one of my
co-defendants cody bates
mentioned previously that he's no longer
with us he was
ended up in a scientologist rehab where
they put him on
antidepressants which had a side effect
of killing yourself and he killed
himself
it's documented the lawsuit is online if
people want to look that up
scientologist rehab yeah where
i don't know don't know but it's
probably arizona or california imagine
so cody bates shows up cody bates was my
right hand man
in charge of sensible things because he
never got high
but after we all got arrested he got so
depressed he went straight to heroin
hence he ended up in the rehab where he
hung himself so cody
bates shows up and this other guy shows
up i'll just call him the dj
and we're sharing our arrest stories so
i tell them you know
bam bam bam bam door flies off the
hinges
swat team raid cody bates is
driving along the freeway
and he looks up in the morning and sees
the helicopter
and he thinks this is a bit strange
everywhere i'm going
there seems to be a helicopter it's like
that scene in goodfellas
in the afternoon he's looking up and lo
and behold
he's he's been driving he's scared to go
anywhere he's just driving he doesn't
want to stop
so he's driving to phoenix tempe mesa
going up and down these
freeways afternoon lo and behold
helicopter next thing he sees
like a motorcade of police cars and
police motorbikes
and they all just he's got motorbikes
all around in cars
and they just take him off the road
that's how he got busted
now the dj it was his first
day at his brand new job
of some of the fundraiser as a
fundraiser
for the republican party
so he he shows up and um
they come in his workplace and arrest
him so i
imagine that was the end of that all
right so all day long
we are just like sharing stories at the
tempe
jail and then there comes a point in
time
where the van comes to take us to
sheriff
joe arpaio's horseshoe
and i'd heard stories about the
horseshoe from wildman previously
because he'd been deported multiple
times he was a menace to society
it would always end up with him in the
horseshoe and
it's a horseshoe formation you go in
you go through the cells you don't know
whether it's night or day because it's
underground but the walls do heat up so
you can detect
you know when when it's midday and you
come out at the very end
and they give you a classification
minimum medium max security
giving you black and white stripes so
you get on your way so i knew
some stories about the horseshoe while
man said last time he was in they
wouldn't give them his name
he was in there for days and you can't
sleep because you're so sardined into
those cells
so we get in the van and i finally see
wildman
for the first time since my arrest
and he said that when he was in the
tempe jail
they were trying to interview my
girlfriend claudia
and he was walking past and he heard him
say
these are very serious charges you're
facing you need to tell us about atwood
and he somehow he broke free of the of
the policeman that
that was taking him to wherever he was
take it from managed to get
stick his head in the room where claudia
was getting interrogated
and goes serious [ __ ]
charges my [ __ ] ass
don't listen to these daft pig bastards
claudia
and then he just goes
and he had this big [ __ ] off vikings
beard and he's been up for days on
smoking crack and crystal meth and he
just looks like an absolute maniac
so we're in the van sharing our arrest
stories and um
speaking to the females now because the
females are with us
first group was about 13 co-defendants
about half
female so when we get to the madison
street jail
there's like a ladder uh steps coming
out the van and the transportation
officers tell the women scout first
now there's a huge line of people
waiting to go into the jail these are
all like the new arrestees
like i described earlier people you know
have just been in altercations with the
police
people who are drunk people who are high
people have been tasered people who've
got injuries
and as they see these women
coming off the van this big line of men
turns around and starts heckling
the women and i can't remember
specifically what they were saying but
it was of a sexual nature
so the women you know while woman who's
very tough was just
you know just look at these guys like
assessing the situation
but the other women looked like they
were really in feeling really insulted
and disrespected so
then the men start to get out of the van
and the guard just yelling everybody to
get out to get down these steps
very quickly so wild man just stops
on the top step and the the cops tell
him to get down he just doesn't move
and he raises his vikings beard and he
opens his eyes
really wide and he looks at all of the
men
heckling the women and he goes hey
that there's my [ __ ] woman
i'll have [ __ ] any of you guys
when we get inside there in a couple of
minutes because that's where we're all
[ __ ] going
if you guys don't shut the [ __ ] up right
now
you're gonna see what's gonna happen to
you
and they all just shut the [ __ ] up right
away
holy [ __ ] he was a good man to get
arrested with
yeah he was 28 stone um by the end of it
and
one stone is 14
pounds i believe what did you say it was
28
stone that was his weight let me just
tell you 14 times 28.
so he was he was 400 pounds in weight
and six foot two
oh my god his fists were twice the size
of mine
and it was just all human teeth marks
all the way along them
now it might be um
it might be an interesting subject going
might be sammy the vault because he's on
youtube now and all of
or anything with him on it is going
viable what was the what was the
story behind all that let's let's get
into that let me just tell you one more
thing so we had a guy working for
us called let's say handsome mark and he
started working for the gravano
enterprise
so he was playing both sides and
one of our customers gave handsome mark
money for a thousand ecstasy but hanson
mart went and got it off
the gravano enterprise instead of us not
only that he was pulled
over by the feds and the pills were
confiscated
so then the customer comes to us well
she went to wild man first i hadn't
authorized what he'd done he just went
and did it himself
so she goes to wild them says look just
gave
you know one of your guys it's ten plus
thousand
he's saying that he got pulled over
there's no pills
there's nothing he could do about it so
wild man went and paid him a visit and
um while man just like he only needs to
punch someone once
and he would usually knock him out so in
this case he punched the guy
and it ended up with the guy's tooth
stuck in between
two of his knuckles so by the time i get
there he's
explaining i've just this guy was
[ __ ] going through sammy the ball
this is what happens to people who go
through sammy the ball he's showing me
he's [ __ ] he's damaged this damaged
fist
was the tooth so like dangling out of
his flesh it wasn't still dangling but
his
knuckles were all [ __ ] up oh my god
yeah by the time i
got up there it was it was later
you